[Musique]
le président de la régie communautaire
de l'eau et de l'assainissement dans le
centre au dc est avec nous dans son
caddie bon jour ils ont pas dit bonjour
à tous à tous les auditeurs cette
période sécheresse en martinique c'est
toujours un moment délicat pour tous les
acteurs de l'eau effectivement c'est un
moment où la ola ressources disponibles
n'est pas suffisante pour satisfaire aux
attentes et aux besoins de l'ensemble
des martiniquais
alors c'est le problème de la sécheresse
et de moins jeunes à l'elysée puisque
nous exploitons essentiellement des eaux
souterraines
c'est la situation d'aujourd'hui la
conséquence c'est quoi puisqu'il faut se
poser la question des conséquences c'est
que les points hauts sont moins bien
alimentés que les points bas on le sait
l'eau s'écoule seulement son poids et
contre se trouve sous les odeurs on est
servi après ceux qui se trouvent un
point bas c'est le cas notamment
il faut propre et il faut qu'on paie
donc normal mort au servage bokolo ses
collègues gravitaire mais quand on
habite les points qu il faut pomper il
faut des équipements électromécaniques
pour pomper l'eau à c'est le cas nous
avons connu des difficultés sur tous les
points hauts du lamentin nous avons
connu également logos difficulté sur les
points hauts de chennevières notamment
les cartes chez coline démarche et c'est
non on connaît on connaît cela il faut
pas qu'ils puissent que la sécheresse a
bien nous sommes habitués restrictions
coupures tournantes ont de vraies têtes
habitué à ce genre de phénomène ce genre
de phénomène pourtant la population a
tendance à l'oublier c'est devenu
insupportable d'être privé de l'espace
de quelques heures vous en tenez compte
les délais d'intervention sur des délais
d'intervention sur un problème alors la
situation d'aujourd'hui telle qu elle s
impose ce qu'on appelle des coupés
autour c'est une coordination qui a été
organisée par les services préfectoraux
on coupe l'eau de manière intermittente
ce qui fait que certains quartiers sont
privés d'eau pendant que nous toute une
journée voire plus mais la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est quelles sont
les causes de cette situation
moi j'ai ma dit que nous ne devrions pas
connaître ce genre de situation
pourquoi pourquoi parce que les lots
disponibles mardi nick lowe naturelles
notamment les eaux de surface
je ne compte même pas les eaux
souterraines devrait permettre de
satisfaire très largement
les besoins de la population et je le
confirme du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
si nous sommes dans cette situation
c'est tout simplement que l'organisation
de la gestion de l'eau n'est pas bonne
elle n'est pas optimale donc vous
comprenez le vous comprenez la
population qui n'est pas satisfaite du
service et qui ne veut même plus
entendre parler d'une heure de coupure
de deux heures de pur que coupures parce
qu'on a déjà évoqué toutes ces questions
ils vont pas qui tu es con impression
que rien ne bouge
et bien moi je dis qu'il ya bien
évidemment archi contiennent des
problèmes techniques mais au delà de ces
problèmes techniques il faut d'aller
vers les choix politiques qui ont
conduit à ces bolingbroke la gouvernance
la gouvernance à mon avis c'est la
question de temps il faut de la saisir
pour aborder des solutions ça fait
longtemps que tous les acteurs et je le
dis je le dis plus gros stack open pour
qui ça peuple à part les tentes à aider
en cas de problème à l'aide loi je
comprends parfaitement ici frais savent
c'est vrai que depuis des années je
m'échine à faire partager cette idée il
faut adapter modifier avec vos baskets
politiques aussi bien évidemment bien
sur ce volet politique
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on n'est pas
aujourd'hui vers dans la dernière ligne
droite de cette autorité unique de l'eau
dans notre île à belleville à moi je
parle de la cacem depuis déjà des années
davantage
nous préconisons une gouvernance
intégrée alors je ne vais pas dire
entité unique ça fait peur à certains en
tout cas ça ne nous fait pas peur mais
je dis qu en attendant d'avoir une
entité unique qui définirait la
politique globale de l'eau sur
l'ensemble du territoire
c'est des politiques d'investissement
politique duquel page politique de la
distribution cohérence des réseaux et
réseaux un schéma dire que c'est la
somme du départ du territoire et non pas
plusieurs petites politiques
territoriales
donc ça fait un moment qu'on le dit
jeudi en attendant d'avoir une entité
unique qui porte la cause toutes ces
problématiques ont besoin au moins avoir
une gouvernance intégrée c'est à dire
que chacun ne voulant pas lâcher sa
compétence en boivent et à se mettre
autour d'une table et définir un schéma
directeur en commun permettez moi
d'insister ils vont pas quitter puisque
ça ne se fait pas puisque tout le monde
semble voir que ça pourrait être une
solution
à qui profite ce crime que ça ne se
fasse pas alors je vais vous le dire
tout ce que je faisais
qui subit n'est ce pas le préjudice
s'agit puisque on a l'eau la plus chère
du monde
en tout cas 5 euros 44 le mètre cube
tout à fait alors nous avons je voulais
des zi d'algérie visité deux trois
exemples concrets
pourquoi beaucoup puissent mesurer les
âges et je pourrais nous avons une
grande usine située dans le nord
atlantique qui s'appelle usine de viviez
que tout le monde connaît la rivière la
capot peut satisfaire aux besoins de
toute la martinique toute l'année et un
potentiel de plus de 75 mètres 1000
mètres cubes jour
aujourd'hui on n'exploite que 20000 ça
c'est une première chose à l'accueil
aura coupé de lois lane où comme il voit
il voit quand même quelques
investissements à faire choix politiques
les investissements au niveau du captage
des investissements au niveau du
traitement au niveau du réservoir de
tête qui se trouve après l' usine d
investissement au niveau des
canalisations bois cheminée cette eau
jusqu au sud de l'île bref s'il ya
quelques investissements qu'il
conviendrait de vs clos pays l'eau c'est
le principe de base dont 3 ça pose
problème
alors ya bien évidemment des problèmes
de subir les volumes de financement mais
je dis quant à vous ces problèmes le
financer il faudrait déjà que les
volontés convergent
il faudrait déjà que les politiques que
j'en fais partie de la critique
s'adresse à moi même il faudrait qu'on
nous le mettions d'accord vous que ces
investissements soient considérés comme
prioritaires
vous avez une capacité de 75 mille
mètres cubes jour on en produit qu'à 20
milles ça c'est déjà un problème il faut
qu'on se mette d'accord sur la
répartition des moyens de financement
pour permettre à cette eau d'irriguer
toute la martinique
deuxième exemple très concret au psg
puis la côte atlantique
prenons la côte caraïbe vous avez la
démarche on ne parlait total qui atteint
un point haut de chercheurs savaient que
la démo se situent à moins d'un
kilomètre le réservoir que ce nouveau
quartier citronnelle louvier la sauce
morestin entre le mono j'étais bien sûr
moins de kilomètres ont beau être des
canalisations vous servir ce quartier
qui s'appelle démarche l'opal c'est
joseph ça passe à fort-de-france ont
pour pour manger à l'eau qui suggérait
d'avoir une canalisation de ces données
mais me dire vos bourreaux ne le fait
pas c'est une année sur deux sites où
n'existe pas
ils vont pas comprendre l'exaspération
des populations
je le dirai que soient ces boues
véritablement expliquer pourquoi la
population et qu'il faudrait citronnelle
dimanche sur moins d'un kilomètre vous
deviez des canalisations le problème est
réglé
pourquoi s'est pas fait c'est parce que
si tout allait si j y ai pas au complot
celle jersey la gazelle est ce que j'ai
dit qu'est ce qui empêche alfred
monthieux président le cap nord à tana
john roos président kacem et eugène
larcher président de l'espace sud de
s'asseoir autour d'une table
quand même pas difficile à trouver le
bon timing pour se rencontrer et
discuter d'une meilleure coordination
entre les services et déjà me pose la
même question que vous passez à bout ce
qui me concerne donc la joie de tout le
monde au nom de la cacem voulait
rencontrer tout le temps si j'ai
rencontré à plusieurs reprises la cacem
a déjà suggéré énormément l'opposition
pour aller vers ce qu'on appelle cette
gouvernance unique ça fait peur l entité
unique
d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion de dire dans
ce cas trop de choses à préserver trop
de confort lorsqu'on a la tête de l'eau
en amérique mais j'en profite pour dire
la quantité unique n'est pas la solution
il mourrait tout résoudre
parce que vous pourrez avoir une entité
unique qui fonctionne mal ce qui est
important c'est une gouvernance
optimiser une gouvernance optimisé pour
que les verts les investissements soient
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
qu'il n'ya pas les projets du sud les
projets du centre
les projets du nord mais si on se
rencontre mais jusqu'à aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas encore mis d'accord sur la
nécessité d'adopter des autres ne nous
dira il vos papiers qu'il faut confier
cette gestion de l'eau à des gens
raisonnables qui sont gérer la ressource
financière pour une autre qualité un
personnel dévoué et d'émissions
respecter et une population satisfaite
on peut comprendre cela ouais on peut
comprendre que le préfet interviennent
non je crois qu'il ne faut pas
nécessairement je pense que les
martiniquais 504 le mètre contact
à la date d'aujourd'hui un niveau de
responsabilité telle kg qui devrait leur
permettre de laisser voler la sans avoir
à faire appel à un préfère où je le sais
à quelle instance supérieure
c'est le sens et la responsabilité
minimale on se bat pause exiger plus de
responsabilités quand on les âges et
goulet et je pense que il faut dire que
les autres partenaires il ya 3
il ya quelques années il y avait six ce
qu'on appelle mettre l'ouvragé madilu
depuis la loi loterie qui était de
revenir à 2-3 ans il n'a plus que trois
les trois communautés d'agglomération
plus la cité m6 ça devrait être plus
facile ça devrait être plus facile aux
contacts que ça ne l'est pas saguenay
pas donc c'est pour cette raison c'est
pas une question vous désespérez je n'ai
pas appris à désespérer de mon pays ni à
désespérer de mes partenaires je me suis
peut-être des politiques de ce pays
donc j'ai ressenti il faut pas sombrer
dans le désespoir il faut continuer à
travailler en ce qui me concerne et au
nom de la cacem je continuerai a
préconisé cette gouvernance intégrée à
faire des choix commun et faire en sorte
que les usagers que les martiniquais
soit véritablement oui mieux servi un
lot notamment et je vais terminer en
rappel dans le prix de l'eau 5 euros 44
le mètre cube loup la plus chère de
france merci d'avoir avec nous c'est
très troublant
merci d'avoir été avec nous ils vont pas
quitte président d'audi si gentils
damoiseaux à mercier
[Musique]